welcome back everybody to LED live on
this special day it is Valentine's Day
today we love having you part of our
show we're going to talk about media
watching love romance movies does it
actually affect your views of love find
out on this episode of LED live as
always it's a pleasure to have you guys
tune in and thank you for watching we
want to thank our patreon donors you
know given us much love over the years
we love you guys to death
you guys have literally supported our
work from the beginning we love it thank
you so much if you don't know about
patreon check it out you get some cool
perks we also have DVDs and videos that
you can rent online Vimeo you can buy
our DVDs on little lights Studios TV
there's a 10% off Valentines code what's
that code now there woo 10% off that's
us showing you some love and yeah 10%
off Valentines you guys check it out we
this is one way that you can support our
ministry as well t-shirts we sell these
kind of cool t-shirts representing today
again and we thank you guys for actually
wearing the t-shirts we want to see some
pictures of it though if you guys buy a
t-shirt from us snap a photo send that
to us and our show yeah we'd love to put
it on our show and show some people
representing so thank you so much for
supporting our ministry in that way so
let's talk about Valentine's Day does
anyone want to take a guess where
Valentine's came from some pagan or
someone okay remember like it had some
pretty horrible origins like it was a
really sad kind of story
well here's what it says on encyclopedia
britannica okay
valentine's Day is also called st.
Valentine's Day so before I read any
further
what do you think is going to have a
connection with that Catholic Catholic
Church right when lovers express their
affection ingredients with gifts the
holiday has its origins in a Roman
festival called Lupercalia I don't know
if I said that right until they
butchered it probably but it was in
mid-february
and the festival which celebrated the
coming of spring included fertility
rites and pairing off of women with men
by a lottery how does that sound to you
candy not okay wow that's interesting
huh at the end of the fifth century Pope
I'm not even gonna say this correctly
jolly assess the first replaced
Lupercalia with st. Valentine's Day and
it has become to what we know about it
today so was this practice in the
Catholic Church right you know I just
wonder bright side in the dark side the
bright side yeah you can give gifts to
like affectionate gifts to your loved
ones and all that and in the background
people are being sold you know it's
rather than only because in Valentine's
Day today we think of it so much
centering around the woman you know what
I mean like no man gets the gifts and
the flowers and all this kind of stuff
and and it's like she'll are like
showering his love interest with those
kind of things but in this that that
doesn't sound really like you know it's
for the woman it's like gratification
for the man kind of interesting so next
question here how do you think the ring
finger became the ring finger ring
finger Oh left hand that's right
left hand why do we wear ring finger on
a ring good question I don't know why
why do I stay on the same plane as you
know men being possessive and getting
what they want wondering even like also
like fertility symbolism or something
there does why
he's on a good roll here so listen to
this this is coming from the
merriam-webster dictionary the ring
finger got its name from the ancient
belief that there was a vein directly
connected with the human heart yes and
that wearing that ring on that finger
might alleviate ailments and it was this
called the leech finger or for similar
reasons oh I don't know that's a finger
cut off is it more danger of being to
death or something I don't think this
actually has any substantial like
science I think yeah I always would have
assumed that the ring finger was just
because that's probably the least finger
you would use I don't know if you're
right-handed or whatever like that you
know it's like if you live you had to
lose one no that's what I would have
guessed okay here's another fun fact
right here where did the actual shape of
the heart to come from
I've always wondered that well with the
origins of this hi this this actually
totally surprised me I'd love to think
that it's from nature and someone just
looked out onto a lake and saw two swans
you know next to each other like wow
that's a beautiful symbol so wow you
you're actually you've got part of that
right okay okay so that's a pretty
that's pretty good guess I'll give you
this you got one word of that right one
yeah it's not from Wakanda yeah nature
okay my gear on it man shaped earth came
from nature listen to this this is
pretty interesting History Channel
actually when I was doing research for
this this popped up on all kinds of
different things so you can find this
the heart-shaped plant was actually used
for birth control as in this interesting
perhaps it's the most unusual theory
concerns the Scylla Thiam if I said that
right it's a flower a little yellow
flower and the species was a giant
fennel that once grew in North African
coastline near the Greek colony of
Cyrene and the ancient Greeks and Romans
used it as both a food flavoring
medicine and medicine
and it supposedly worked wonders as a
cough syrup but it was most famously
known to as the form of birth control
now the seed of this the state of this
plant is in the shape of a heart
the seed is and so the Greeks and the
Romans they actually used it so heavily
with birth control that they actually
put it on their coin so it was on the
coin and that's like one of the first
times that the heart was being slowed
but they don't love is not having
children isn't this just crazy there's a
very simple devil used to actually
illustrate love was literally used to
kill what happens when you make love
when you just beat a bunch of these
seeds and just hope that works I don't I
don't I I don't know what actually the
method what of it was but that's
actually where it came from
okay so that's just some fun facts about
you know Valentine's love you might be a
little surprised when you look this kind
of stuff up but how about this the
reason we wanted to bring this
discussion up today is a lot of people
you know we discuss evil movies all the
time and like you know terrible stuff
Satan's doing this and you know look at
behind the scenes and there's a lot of
people that are like yeah but I don't
watch any of that it's true right my
wife and I we only watch love stories
you know right your wife ever made you
sit down and watch a love story your
wife ever sit down and make you lunch a
love story yeah
years ago framily right yeah my wife was
a big fan like what was a story
give me one that you remember watching
that you were you would snuggle up and
cuddle and watch this movie together I
don't know there was anything on repeat
but I remember we remember when we went
to go see Phantom of the Opera okay okay
in the theater no that's a messed up
love story it is so that'll go well with
the theme that I'm about ready to
present but yeah I mean what what was
the problem with the fan of the Opera oh
wow it's been so long it's the beast
that lives in the bottom of yeah I mean
opera and he's like you know the one
that
kind of has rules it is weird saturation
with the girl and it seems like he
kidnapped her or something you know and
interesting parallels it's almost like
Beauty and the Beast right yeah I could
see that she falls in love with this
this character that everybody rejected
and
to me I see super spiritual parallels
with - sure how are you any rent Mantic
movies that really get you sobbing and
hearts popping ah no no titles are
coming to mind I'm sure there are but no
titles are coming to mind so is there a
love interest in Kennedy's life that
we're all married years oh you know
Mikey how about you I know I can't think
of a title but it was like a Christian
movie about fireproof no it was uh it
was like a chat type thing you don't
remember but I do remember like I'm on
the online dating one yeah I think
that's Christian mingle or something
yeah I remember saying that one I'm
talking like a love story you don't you
guys never watched I mean if I was gonna
watch something I'd be more interested
in it romantic comedy then then you know
sappy love story yeah yeah was she good
she okay fine
so huffington post posted this really
interesting articles how movies in
television actually changed the way you
think about love now I found this pretty
interesting and what the article was
basically highlighting was a study that
they did in the University of Michigan
they took 625 students 392 of them or
female and they wanted to see if
specifically romantic movies had an
impact on people's ideals about love and
specifically also looking at does TV
shows have an influence over their
romantic lives and this is this is what
they actually found out they were shown
about 17 sitcoms 93 romantic films such
as like 500 days of summer crazy Crazy
Stupid Love never heard of that one
and in time
never heard of that one kind of oh okay
about the question asks me about which
which love story I like 50 first dates
did you guys remember that's right
that's right reminder every day who he
is
sure of highlight-reel every day that's
right I thought somebody was going to
bring up my name is Manny Gomez no the
princess princess right but a bear to
die but anyway they showed all these
particular can people that were a part
of this study all these different movies
and then they really wanted to ask him a
question afterwards you know how how did
this impact your ideas of love they had
this whole questionnaire that people
filled out
now here's what emerged out of this
study the more exposure to romantic
movies led to a greater tendency to
believe that love finds a way and will
overcome all obstacles what do you think
about that what do you think about that
concept of just love conquers and
overcomes every obstacle it's a nice
concept okay I don't know how realistic
it is but yes so we read it again the
more exposure to romantic movies leads
to a greater tendency to believe that
love finds a way and can overcome all
obstacles yeah I see I see two sides
because in the concept of God and men
yes of course that concept applies God
is shows us unconditional love it does
conquer all but then when you're talking
about human relationships it can be
really devastating to go into a
relationship with that idea and then it
crumbles and then like it seems like
your whole philosophy or your whole
outlook is just you know becomes nothing
because it didn't work love is messy
love is not always this this there's a a
rainbow at the end of the story right
mm-hmm God so loved the world that He
gave His Son who came down was died
murdered so that everybody could have
eater
life but there's a lot of people who
will not have eternal life that's true
love demonstrating itself in a story
that didn't play out very well I'm gonna
mean it's true so the idea that just
love is going to conquer everything is
is in a spiritual sense it's not exactly
the way that that it plays out and
you'll see what I mean by this by the
end of this this little study here
number two does anyone else have any
comments before we move on on now you're
getting into are you gonna get into like
princess stories anything like that um
we can we can we can definitely open up
that can of worms a little bit I'm gonna
show you some more examples yeah I'm
gonna show you some more like adult type
shows that that that illustrate love
what everybody's like you know watching
and some of the most popular movies that
are out there the more exposure to
marriage themed reality show so now
we're talking about television I mean
that's what was about movies the more
exposure to marriage themed reality
television shows led participants to
believe that love at first sight was
good or can happening and that true love
will be nearly perfect mmm yeah how many
of those reality stars are still
together today only after the show ends
you know what was the Nick Nick Cannon
and just you talking like it was a
bachelor and stuff like that okay
Jessica Simpson and Nick Lachey wasn't
it I don't know yeah I thought you were
talking about reality TV shows because
most of those like reality TV show yeah
were they did they hook up on a reality
TV show no they had
but ended in disaster but what they
showed you you know could easily be like
you know love at first sight you brought
up the bachelor that's a perfect example
in love at first sight you know ii mean
it's like i don't know how long those
people are actually with each other i
mean i don't know that i would classify
it that way to me it's like love by bank
account but not by bank account or love
by wow you have the right shape we're
going you know forward with this i I
don't know on the other hand watching TV
sitcoms is the third thing that came out
of this study led to a negative view of
romance and very little endorsement for
concepts like love finds away love it's
reciting Idol is eye realization and one
and only those so those are those things
right there mmm those things came out of
if you watch TV sitcoms because how
what's the nature of a sitcom how does
how does comedy work know you're putting
someone down that's right you make fun
of people right remember married with
children she was constantly making fun
of her husband who's it yeah fern yeah
could couldn't do anything right alright
so it sat on the couch what came out of
this study was if you watched those kind
of shows and we're exposed to those
you're walking away with that no no this
this this there's little there's little
ways that you don't see value in it yeah
which leads to the other premise that
they're talking about and that is you
know there are other relationships out
there for you you don't need to be
necessarily yoked to one person which
gets reinforced by shows like Sex in the
City and things like that you know or or
what's the other one Desperate
Housewives you know there's multiple
people in the live right and it's you
know it's usually this story of husbands
mean and abusive but the guy that's
mowing the lawn is this cute young guy
the cool guy yeah exactly and it's like
you're you're psychologically messing
with the audience to desire well well
her husband's not really nice to hear
him her anyway so she should go with
that guy you know what I mean right and
it's so consistent yes throughout all of
them yes we've seen that in the show
Lucifer that we did an LED program on so
check that out but there was a scene
where she goes into the confession and
she's
you know talking about how she really
likes the limo driver and not her
husband and so he steps into the
confession he's like well you should
totally go after the limo driver man you
know reinforcing that just just go with
what your desire is right right you know
you did a talk that talked about some
statistics and like sexuality that was
novel and right you know if you're
exposed to those kind of things over and
over and over again I mean there's a
reason why they call these things
programs right now they're literally
programming your mind your life to react
in that kind of a way so listen to this
the tail end of this thus the
researchers suggests that the behaviors
shown in entertainment genre are
actually being imprinted into our views
of romance mm-hmm think about that we're
like we're like dodo birds yeah hey
we're just running around my god what
can I imprint on right and it's like
what we're viewing and what we're
watching is literally giving us a
picture of what romance should look like
what the relationship should be like now
I'm gonna spin this back into the Bible
because if you're reading what real
relationships look like in the Bible
right the Holy Spirit is imprinting on
your mind what that relationship should
look like and then you're you're you're
trying to go and find that or recreate
that and that's that's why even as a
parent it's extremely important as as us
parents to model proper love to our
children yeah more than what we say to
our children the way that we interact
with our wives is literally how our kids
are gonna view a relationship you don't
mean it's true what's happening in the
home is their sitcom that's right mm-hmm
that's right so they go on to say that
for example watching lavish dates such
as The Bachelor lead the viewers to
idolize love or idealize love while
watching a couple bicker on a sitcom
leads them to more negative impressions
of marriage what's wrong with lavish
dates
well guys husbands yes yes so you know
let's talk about I think what the
problem is is what you're watching are
moment in time and so if what you're
putting before your eyes is this
fantastic moment in time and then
another one and then another one and
then another one it adds up to this
collective son of well that's what love
is it's all this grand moments of time
that get idealized and that's what you
expect you go in the relationship and
it's like wait a minute
it's not like this it's like little kids
that watch TV you know Baby Einstein
they're watching and they think a farm
is something's popping up in your face
all the time and they get to a farm in
they're like this is totally boring like
everything moves so slowly yeah same
principle unrealistic expectations
exactly roses every day Yeah right
yeah and the fact is guys gonna go to
work for nine hours a day or whatever
and you're lucky if you get to spend
time on the weekend and things like that
it's just life you know right so let's
talk about a movie that was popular when
I was actually younger like high school
for those of you that don't know there's
an actor named Leonardo DiCaprio who and
he was in this film called the Titanic
have you seen this film I have okay have
you seen this film no have you seen this
film oh yeah okay I've seen this film ah
maybe I've seen this film like lots of
times I probably have too but this I
remember when this came out in high
school I remember people literally going
to the theater five six seven eight nine
oh yeah I mean this was like oh yeah
they were read the complete movie there
were my people yeah this is our song
every week that's our like a whole year
that's right Wow that's right that's
weird because that's not - at least
twice in the theater I didn't it was
like some that everybody did oh I mean I
literally had friends that had watch
this movie so many times they could
literally quote the whole thing was it
was unreal Wow so now that you guys have
seen this tell me the story
Titanic well he he's on this ship the
Titanic with this character he grows and
they you know he's he's like this rough
character you know if you look at it
like lady in the [__] you know like
he's the he's the rough dog who has all
this freedom and stuff and she comes
from upper-class society and I'm trying
to remember she's engaged I think whoa
so the love story really centers around
a woman who goes on a ship who's engaged
to another man who she was unhappy with
and falls in love with this well it was
I think it was like you know more of an
arranged marriage type thing because
it's like well you need to marry in your
class and this guy's in your class and
nobody else is and so that's that's kind
of why you know it was just like you
know you're rich he's rich let's keep
the rich people together I still think
it's pretty messed up that they would
put something out into society saying
that here's this person that's engaged
and she falls in love with somebody else
I think this is one of the examples of
playing with people's psychological you
know desires for people to be happy you
know and it's just kind of a messed up
situation see the sparks and you're like
oh I hope they get together yeah can't
can can you think of anything that
happened in the movie that is not
biblically okay but those kind of things
think about this every little girl that
goes and watches these things
pre-marriage
you are imprinting what happens into a
relationship okay how about this movie
this was a little bit later I was
probably ever seeing this you ever seen
this but you know what it is yeah
Nicholas Sparks
yeah you guys I did you I did - there
was some pretty emotional scenes in this
okay so I'm just looking at the picture
I want you to look at this picture and I
want to analyze the picture and tell me
what you see a beautiful scene of a man
a woman she showed a ring of in the rain
yes you got a real finger Lainey liddie
Keith Keith Keith Johnny's johnny
hawkeye's raining okay so she got a ring
on her finger what does that mean she's
either engaged or married
okay she's engaged not to this man hmm
let me see a pattern you know what I
mean like this is what they're putting
out there once again she's engaged to
this other person that you know she goes
back and tries to you know rekindle some
old flame that she had to see if she
still had feel
for him and let's say about the man I
mean it's not even like she's trying to
hide it it's a massive ring on her
finger given to her by someone else and
he's exactly here she's making out with
the guy and she's like literally like
flaunted right before her wedding I mean
this is like literally like very close
to win and she was supposed to be
married I wonder if there's this this
fear that society kind of puts out there
and the fear goes something like this
I might miss out on an opportunity for
true love whatever it is that true love
is you know however it's defined but
true love and so people get this idea
that man you know what if I miss it and
so they they want to experiment if you
will and find out if this other person
is really the true love and if it is
well I don't want to miss out on that so
I got a ditch this other guy or other
girl so I don't know I wonder if it
seems like that seed has been planted
like you you could miss out and if you
did I think what that means is you would
be unhappy and miserable for the rest of
your life or you would have regrets and
nobody really wants to have regrets okay
so that's right and it always leaves a
question mark in the back of your head
even if you are married did I make the
wrong choice should I have been with
this other person that I was dating
before you know what I mean that like
like I I'm a firm believer if you've
been in a romantic relationship which
you should not be in until you get
married I'm a firm believer of that but
let's just say I mean let's say whatever
happens you got into a romantic
relationship before I don't believe it's
okay to continue a relationship whether
it be verbal on the phone calling
texting throughout your life if you're
in a married relationship I just I don't
think that's okay there's always
feelings this kind of a thing is what is
literally under the surface of what I
mean we're humans we tie our hearts
together with each other and so you tend
to like start to only remember the good
things like oh that was a fun time you
for
all those things right right so I left
it myself the other day because I
realized yes I have been affected
because I'm a friend of mine she
recently got married and she's in her
early 20s talking like 22 and I was like
oh my goodness that is crazy early her
life is over you know like I would I
could never see myself getting married
at this age yeah I just had to stop and
be like wow like that's interesting that
I have this mindset that whether I
realize it or not my view of marriage is
like yeah that's it settled down can't
do fun stuff anymore have all these
responsibilities and one thing about
these movies is that do you realize
there's no ending or conclusion or next
big step to this secondary relationship
so it's like this person is either
they're married or they're about to get
married but they fall in love with
someone else and then the movie ends
like there's no progression of that
relationship to marriage or to something
else so it's like you know keep marriage
kind of on the side or in the back and
continue having fun or flings with
different people and having adventure
and I really think about commitment in a
sense I'm glad that you brought that up
okay because keep that thought right
there okay because at the end of this
I'm going to show you some studies that
they actually show you what happens when
you have that mentality all right but
let's continue forward okay I want to
show you some more modern movies have
you ever heard of a film called
professor Marston and the Wonder Woman
this is the gentleman that wrote Wonder
Woman mm-hmm I've heard of it a show or
a movie
no it's a movie okay I don't know if
it's come out is it come out yes oh yeah
yeah it's already came out um
just analyze from the photos here what
do you think this is about it was
definitely an action film yeah there's a
lot of action in but what is what's up
with the ropes okay no tell me so the
guy is there and I know too much
no this is a kosher show but I want you
to really just get in the habit of
looking at a photo and they're telling
you a lot a pseudo two females on one
man okay BAM now what is the words that
are on this picture what does it say
every one day interesting ever wonder
what can I also make a distinction that
the women are clearly complete opposites
look at the way their address you have
their poses yep and that's purposeful
okay of course the other thing that
strikes me is everybody's partly in
shadow and partly in the light which
suggests there's a side of them that's
hidden and a side of them that is
exposed
[Music]
okay okay
candies candy can't leave the ropes
alone so I'm gonna show you what the
ropes are and this is a little clip from
the trailer I actually can't show you a
lot of the trailer because it's way to
propose the different colors you know
read as oftentimes you know suggesting
provocative or racy or bold you know
blue is more cold like indifferent right
so I'll just I'll just throw the cat out
here he is in a relationship with both
women he's actually married to the one
on the right and he is a professor and
this is his student and they decided to
have a three-way triangle relationship
and then actually Wonder Woman was
created under yes the Wonder Woman
comment yes and hmm there's ropes
involved which were obviously about
bondage and sadomasochism gonna know
that kind of when you say Wonder Woman
came out of that she's like a child of
that or like influenced by that this was
his real life and he wrote a comic about
his real life this is the real professor
who roses Liz Lemon based on a true
story true story if they're real like me
the rope the lasso of truth right and
interesting how they're using this
Wonder Woman for like women's power and
yeah and if you know anything about
Wonder Woman you know in the comic well
in the movies they portray the
male/female relationship right but if
you know the comic storyline Wonder
Woman comes like it's from the island of
thir Mystica or something like that and
aphrodite's yeah I mean the island is
only inhabited by women and they at
least the writers indicate that yes
there are sexual relationships that
happen so the fact that they're showing
both happen here is reflect is reflected
in the comics and who knows if we'll see
in the movies but so here's a little bit
of it what the comic Wonder Woman is
about is this what you really want
after Marston
every issue of Wonder Woman is filled
with violence torture and sadomasochism
this abnormal behavior and their comic
hmm so I only wanted to show you a short
clip bad I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna
suggest to you you don't need to see
this you don't even need to Google this
not good but a three-way relationship is
not something that the Bible would
obviously describe as anything good now
here is a interview with one of the
actors listen to what he has to say sex
addicts and then you know these people
loved each other and they were in a
loyal three-way relationship and but
after we'd had the conversations and
then we started to play these characters
you know sitting down at the dinner
table with the two women and the
children from both the women and the dad
it became very very normal very very
quickly because it was pure the what
they had was a pure love for each other
and they were there for each other
through thick and thin and those
children were born through love and so
there's quite beautiful and if anything
it just informs people you know that it
takes also love that an acceptance and
and that love is the most important
thing because no matter who you love
it's just that you love when you love
purely
like normalizing polygamy normalising
polygamy but listen to listen to even
how the actor describes now thinking
about this an actor when he has to get
into a role he has to really immerse
himself in that role when he's sitting
there talking about being with the
family and there's two women and lots of
children and he was like yeah this isn't
this isn't really very weird no you know
and he's placing himself in that
situation right what does that mean for
us that are watching these kind of
things and placing ourselves in that
situation he's being normalized just by
being in the room like that
what's the viewership being normalized
watching this whole thing as well yeah
well here's the thing the Bible doesn't
promote this at all however it doesn't
shy away from it or doesn't leave it out
there are stories in the Bible um that
have polygamous relationships but it
also tells you what came out of those
relationships the confusion the
heartbreak they're just messiness and
it's letting you know in kind of like an
example why we shouldn't get into
something like that because something's
documented as historical fact in the
Bible doesn't mean it's condoning it
exactly this was in the Bible okay he
also said something at the very end that
I think was very eye-catching right
doesn't matter who you love just matters
or how you love just matters that you
love with all of your heart yeah or how
it is yeah wait what I think it doesn't
matter yes we learn how you love all
those are hugely important I believe I
don't believe just because the sake it's
love you know you can love this desk
I love cup you know like there's there's
things that you know you you you you you
have to be careful with how that's
defined yeah especially
it's interesting a man is saying this
looking at the history of it doesn't
matter how you love and how women get
the short end of the stick in that
regard you know you're my wife so he
this is it what you have to do and you
can't say no to me and all these things
oh but I love her it's out of love like
to say something like that is actually
really scary right I wonder how many
polygamous relationships exist where
there's one woman
and two or three men yeah how would that
feel that would no that's a good point
yeah that's a good point what doesn't
work by the way all right let's talk
about it's getting darker in here what
about this one that's really messed up I
mean I I'm gonna not even ask the
question if you've ever seen this I'm
hoping you don't see this I hope no one
in our audience sees this but I want to
just I wanted to point something out to
illustrate something with this this this
film right the idea that love is tying
up a woman and beating her and you know
or doing this stuff that's not love this
is this is a a depiction of lust yeah
define what is the difference between
lust and love anybody want to give me a
definition of this and that'll be it
hard do I just put a solid devlin I can
give you a solid definition lust is to
take love is to give so when you lust
after something I want to suck your
blood
don't do you know what I mean that that
description that's why Twilight all of
these these vampire movies they're
they're taking life from you and that is
the very definition of lust and even
though lust can appear as love it is not
love love is giving others focused you
would never want to hurt your mate you
know what I mean and and this is like
hurting your mate and trying to tell
people that that is love it's what's
more twisted is that you're hurting them
because they want to be hurt because
there's rules around this kind of what
would you call it this practice
engagement between a couple yeah sorry
it's so like there's like a ghost and
you said art no I mean I was gonna say
something I was gonna say are there
because I can show you a poster for one
of these films or a book cover or
something that says no more rules well
within don't ask me how I know this but
within people within the the community
in which people partake in this there's
these guidelines there's like even safe
words and negotiations like before we
even do this
let me know what your limit is and all
this because of course this stuff can
get really dangerous and
life-threatening I'm depending on by the
ranking so it's that's another thing too
of how unrealistic this is cuz the
banner says no rules and we're all
taunting no rules love whoever love
however but when it comes to actually
doing it they're like oh wait no but I'm
not we need some boundaries yeah exactly
yeah even though our boundaries are like
weak and way out there unrealistic
realistic so this is this is a bad
depiction of love you brought up
cartoons and you know what about
princesses cartoons and stuff I see this
same similar type thing I mean we did
this led on on on all the princesses
that really talked about you know
they're supposed to be in love with the
prince over here but then they fall in
love with the thief just like in Aladdin
or you know this same theme attic story
happens over and over and over again and
it's a wrong picture I believe that's
putting what love is in in people's
minds here's what the Bible has to say
first Corinthians 15:33 says do not be
deceived evil communications will
corrupt good manners yeah I mean you
think about that like you know movies
that that are same things that are
lustful or corrupt or Oh check her out
or whatever like that that's their first
you know interaction or she's just so
hot or they just meet and they end up in
bed all those those things right there
there those will corrupt people yeah we
talked about The Bachelor earlier I
wanted to point this out this was two of
the posters and I believe it's kind of
from the same season around the same
season and I'm assuming that these two
were actually in a relationship together
because over here it says a perfect Bend
right and that's the little tagline that
they're using and then for the
Bachelorette it says from Ben 226 new
men
so I'm assuming that this person was at
once either on the show with him or they
were together and now she's on her own
show and she's gotten out 26 new man in
her life that's terrible what's
frustrating just looking at the the
poster you know why does he
why is he relaxed fully clothed right
looking all well put together and the
woman has to be laying on the floor and
this you know provocative yeah I'm
looking for the man to get the trophy
wife he's got to have some nice good job
with a business suit on and and the
woman for her to get that security that
guy with the nice a wallet
she's got to put herself out there and
like no that's just that's right that's
been shown to us through rap videos and
everything that's right
but this is such a wrong picture of love
that this is actually a graph from 2002
to 2014 of how many of the marriages
actually worked out and the bachelor
between those years there was only 18
out of 18 seasons only two marriages
actually worked out well that's bad odds
for the Bachelorette ten seasons only
three marriages actually worked out so
that is five Darryl's works were hooked
on watching hookups that eventually
ended a disaster yeah and you know I had
a when I when I was in Los Angeles I had
a friend of mine that worked on one of
these dating shows I don't think it was
the bachelor or the Bachelorette but it
was like one of those kind of things and
you know they film 810 hours out of the
day 12 hours sometimes all day long but
then there's stuff that happens all
night long and she says that these
contestants are just sleeping with each
other all night long like oh like like a
revolving door all the all the people
like one after another scheduling them
basically Wow and there's terrible
things that you never see on TV and so
you can wonder if you're doing that how
can these relationships actually ever be
successful
Matthew 6:22 we've brought this verse up
multiple times on this show
and it says the light of the body is the
eye if therefore the eye be single the
whole body will be full of light but if
the eye be evil the whole body shall be
full of darkness if the light that is in
thee be darkness how great is with art
is that darkness if you're taken in
darkness through your eyes and all this
wrong depictions of love there's going
to be consequences to that our brains
are imprinting this is this is one of
the reasons why you know pornography is
such a damaging thing because you see we
have especially the males you know we
talked about us I in printing right
we're like little dodo birds and we're
very visual we need to visually see the
form and the woman like we like that as
a male right and if you've never had
that kind of a visual stimuli as a
stimulation and you get engaged you go
to this wedding everybody that's there
is there to like you know cheer you on
everybody's in support you have this big
build-up and then you go home with that
bride that night and she takes her
clothes off and your your mind is taking
pictures bop bop bop and you're trying
to recreate what is attractive to you
right now if you have all these
premarital experiences of that you're
taking photographs of all these other
women or you're taking mental pictures
with pornography you're imprinting
picture over picture of a picture over
picture of picture now when you go to
look your mind goes to look and see what
is attractive to you all you see is a
blurry face and that's the damage that's
happening because we're taking in we're
imprinting what we're watching and
that's what's becoming what we're
attracted to Wow and that's why I think
it's very dangerous just like
pornography is dangerous it's dangerous
with these love stories that really have
all of these elements that are just bad
from from a biblical perspective I once
read an article I think it was this year
even that said all of these things these
love stories that take you on this
emotional rollercoaster ride they're
basically emotional pornography
that's what it is that's right that's a
good that was a clever way to describe
that's a good description of that so
here we go back to Ken D here about what
happens if you're in all of these other
relationships not getting married too
early folks on the family had an article
that popped up premarital sex has a
greater risk for divorce did you know
that yeah obviously right so there's
actually been studies they list off all
these different studies data from the
national survey family growth indicate
that women who are sexually active prior
to marriage face considerably higher
risk of marital disruption than women
who have virgin brides I mean that's
that's that's pretty straight forward
it's it's it's actually study after
study has shown that there was another
study here in 1994 the massive and
highly respected national health and
social life survey conducted at the
University of Chicago was the first
serious fully reputable reputable study
of sexual behavior in America and it
found a marked connection between
premarital sex and elevated risk of
divorce so check out this graph over
here we have a graph that they that they
came up with this whole study and in the
very zero partner portion that means
that people who waited till marriage to
have sexual relationships with their
spouse actually experienced the lowest
amount of divorce I know that zero
partners then I want you to notice if
they had one prior look at the how how
much height went up 15 percent went
higher if they had two partners only two
partners they found the actual peak
almost at two partners then notice this
it goes down with three partners four to
five six to seven and then so back up if
you have ten plus partners it was the
highest amount but why do you think it
went down right here I think I kind of
have an idea so if you have one sexual
partner and it it's outside marriage or
whatever then that just kind of builds
up your curiosity all I'm gonna do
but then by the time you have this
second one or third or whatever you know
then you kind of have had a feel and
you're like well I need to settle down
you know I've already kind of
experimented or whatever but if you're
up in the teens you're just like this is
my lifestyle basically I ain't trying to
settle down or whatever right right
right so you are hitting the nail on the
head they said that when you actually
have just a few partners before marriage
you're comparing with those people and
so the comparison between two people is
like you know if if your current husband
or wife is you know not quite as
exciting as your other one then you have
this like real heavy comparison between
those two and so you're more likely to
be like well actually you know I kind of
liked that one better and I'm gonna jump
ship with that relationship whereas if
you had multiple partners and you
realize oh wow everybody's kind of
broken and it's like it kind of gets
worse and worse they noticed that okay
you kind of settle down but then when
you get to the ten plus you really start
to see this huge graph go up so sex
plays a major role in marriage major
role you know you want to stay married
you want to be married and have that
marriage be actual functional they say
the happiest check this out Psychology
Today
study after study the happiest people in
a marriage are people that literally
didn't have sex before no I've heard
studies that say the most satisfying sex
is between married couples straight out
and as opposed to dating or whatever
that's right cuz you get to know that
person you need to know what they like
or where it's more open and and you do
care more about pleasing that person
instead of just trying to please
yourself so that's right I wanted to
read this to you and I know you know for
our audience out here and especially if
you've got young kids watching hopefully
you're watching with your parents this
is kind of a heavy tough subject matter
here but you guys need to know what the
statistics are if you've never done
research on this listen to this 70 to 90
percent is
recent studies suggest that adolescents
have sex before 18 whoa yes all right
yeah
and they actually have sex within the
first month of dating so that that is
like you know it actually makes a lot of
sense yeah it's it's a high percentage
that's actually experiencing multiple
partners and and and this kind of thing
it's very rare that people will actually
wait and tell theirs that that seems to
be the progression and shows and movies
you meet them you like them you have sex
that is the whole reason we're having
this show and I'm glad you brought that
up you watch these things repeatedly
over and over again your kids watch
these romantic movies over and over
again you are planting in their mind
what a relationship should look like and
the order of events I meet you you're
hot let's go
it is mainly an adventure what do I keep
seeing over and over on TV okay this
must be the next step that's right
professor listen to this professor Dan
bugs be of Brigman Young University
studied 2035 married couples ranging
from 19 to 71 married less than 6 months
before they were 20 and dr. Busby
claimed not only did the couples who
waited until after marriage to have sex
rape their sex life better that they
reported that their marriages were more
stable and satisfying at their
communication was better than the
couples who did not wait isn't that
beautiful
even if my skepticism is that's the guy
the PhD guy that's right in this article
he says even if my skepticism remain my
entrance were my interest was rekindled
when the claims of the study were picked
up by the news and media blogs aol.com
health declared delaying sex credited
for my marriage making my marriage
stronger across the Atlantic The
Economist echoed chastity before
marriage may have its uses after the
Bible was right well the Bible actually
right right now you gotta be aware of
some of the dark things that our world
is engaged in and aware of if you have
Netflix at home I was pretty shocked
when I when I found this out there's a
whole new Netflix show
that they just put out and recently
released and it's called sex explained
and it is actually all about on this
theater there yeah exactly
you know Mikey kind of hit the nail on
the head here that is too many people in
the bed together and you know when I
kind of looked at this for just a brief
second I mean I literally had to turn
away even before the credits got done
because it was just like terrible but
this is this is stuff that's out there
and they're trying to explain like this
is what it is and you know sex is just
natural and you know it's just part of
things the way that we show love and
it's just all about love love conquers
all and you can start to see this is the
fruit of all of these kind of films and
movies and musics and everything that's
pushing us in the wrong direction of a
picture of love yeah and you know what
like when we were growing up things like
this weren't on mainstream television
you had to go in the through the curtain
of the video around store to get this
kind of stuff
this is the kind of stuff that's on
everybody's home television now I mean a
kid can just a kid can go through and be
like oh well I want that explained and
within five minutes they get way more of
an explanation than they ever or is it
really explanation or just graphic you
know I didn't watch it so I actually
don't know what no I mean like in those
first five minutes like I read this I
read the description and it's basically
saying this is this is just you know how
yeah how it works how the mechanics work
and this is how all the yeah I mean it's
just not good
I think it's funny how our body or our
minds allow us to fool ourselves you
know like we think we believe this or
will do this when this happens but in
the moment it's like everything that you
condition your mind takes over and
you're like wow how did I get here
that's right that's why you have to be
like Daniel and purpose in your heart
before you get to that if you are a
young person you know 13 years old in
younger you have to make decisions about
this now if your parent you're a parent
you need to pray for prayerfully pick
the time that you need to talk
your children about these kind of topics
because this stuff is all out in the
world and you know it's like we don't
have time to cover all the little
cartoons and everything but this is
being put out in a lot of kids
programming as well so listen to what
the Bible has to say first Corinthians
7:2 says nevertheless to avoid
fornication let every man have his own
wife and let every woman have her own
husband what do you notice about this
verse exclusive exclusive it is saying
to avoid those kind of things you know
this is how God designed us to be
it also says let a man leave his father
to become one flesh so two not three or
four that's right these are instructions
like like there's no there's no it's not
ambiguous at all like it's telling you
how it is that's right
that's right I love this verse coming
from proverbs 18:22 whoever findeth a
wife findeth a good thing and obtaineth
the favor of the Lord Amen right I mean
mm-hmm
it is a blessing to be married right
guys yes
candy someday yes it is I you know I
think you know it is a wonderful thing I
look forward to going home and spending
time with my wife I I love doing things
that put a smile on her face I mean
that's just what I get enjoyment out of
it and helping her out doing simple
things like doing the dishes cleaning
the house it's Valentine's Day if you
have a love interest out there do
something for them and you will see
their life light up right and and that's
that's not just one day that you should
be doing that you should be experiencing
that every day with your spouse it's a
blessing from the Lord
Hebrews 13:4 says this marriage is
honorable in all and the bed undefiled
but the whoremongers and adulterers God
will judge you know what's interesting
about this verse the exact same activity
can be an absolute blessing or you can
do the exact same activity and you can
go to hewi give you from eternity
but there's a promise you know you can
take this a vowel before God and it's
like this is the gift I've given you -
this is what I've made it for it's right
not to be perverted and do all these
things and you know to involve pain and
all that you know that's right that's
right so we hope that you guys got a
blessing out of today's show and once
again much love coming from us to you
guys
all the love and support that you've
given to us if we could you like we
could have little hearts popping right
here yeah showing you guys our love
because you've shown us much love and we
hope that you have a wonderful day put a
smile on someone's face if you're
married put a smile and smile in your
spouse's face or do you know do
something wonderful for your children
today but don't just make it today make
it every day and reflect the love of
Christ once again thanks for watching
LED live check out our website little
light Studios dot TV and thanks again
for your support we'll see you next
Friday
[Music]